[Applaudissements]
favier
oui voilà
[Applaudissements]
une ville coupée en deux des destins de
milliers de personnes se sont joués sur
ce que l'on a appelé la ligne de
démarcation
c'est une page d'histoire oubliés de la
deuxième guerre mondiale qui touche le
coeur de vierzon en mai 40
la ville subit toutes les catastrophes
elle est inondé par une crue
exceptionnelle
meurtri par des bombardements dans le
même temps les derniers combats font
rage les soldats refusent de hisser le
drapeau blanc
les allemands auront finalement le
dessus les envahissent la mairie et puis
m'a tout de suite il installe la croix
gammée ondes en eau de la ville et puis
le 20 juin 40
on n'est pas encore aux tractations avec
la ligne de démarcation ce sera dans les
jours qui suivent et puis ce qui fait
que le cher ayant été choisie manière
sont littéralement coupé en deux vous
avez un quartier que la zone libre
l'autre quartier qui sont en zone en
zone occupée c'est pour ça que
maintenant voyons voir le cette fameuse
ces histoires autour de la ligne de
démarcation 22 juin 40 pétant serre la
main d'hitler l'armistice est signé à
rethondes et officialise l'accord sur
l'existence des deux zones
les habitants de vierzon ne se doute pas
quelles seront les conséquences de ce
traité sur leur vie quotidienne
c'est un peu la stupeur tout d'un coup
pour ces personnes qui habitent sont au
coeur de la france
absolument pas habitué à voir des
contrôles d'avoir d'un passer une
frontière
on n'est pas du tout dans des
territoires habitué des zones frontières
est donc désormais ils vont devoir vivre
au quotidien avec avec cette frontière
où il va falloir montrer son décès pas
c'est tout simplement pour franchir la
une démarcation la ligne de 1200km coupe
la france en deux d'est en ouest des
pyrénées au jura et traverse tout le
département du cher
elle suit le cheikh jusqu'à la hauteur
environs de sainte thorette hélas après
elle bifurque donc elle englobe le sud
de l'agglomération de bourges en passant
par le subdray et rui plain pied
et donc là aussi ça sera un secteur de
passage clandestin très régulier parce
qu'effectivement bien sûr toutes les
personnes qui arrivent à bourges ont
aussi contacté un certain nombre de
passeurs bérurier pour franchir la ligne
de démarcation sur sur ces secteurs
selon le voisin à 98 printemps mais elle
n'a rien oublié de cette période
troublée à l'époque elle avait 17 ans et
travailler dans la quincaillerie
familiale à vierzon très vite face à
l'exode tout le monde s'est improvisé
passeur pas trop comme employé il s'est
trouvé comme on habitait au bord de la
nationale des gens qui cherchaient à
passer la démarcation qui s'est installé
entre temps qui ne savait pas comment
faire et on a commencé avec des moyens
assez sommaire à leur donner des astuces
pour essayer de passer et nous en sommes
arrivés très rapidement à trouver un
moyen beaucoup plus efficace
c'est-à-dire fabriquer des fausses des
des fausses cartes d'identité au nom de
gens qui avaient délaissé par ces
allemands pour faire cesser ce vice il
fallait aussi une photographie et
surtout un tampon obtenue grâce à la
complicité du syndicat du commerce
ce stratagème a permis de faire passer
des clandestins au poste-frontière
devient on bourgneuf other distorted
usine quand les douaniers étaient moins
attentifs
c'était très dangereux pour tout le
monde c'est certain mais on était on
était lancé là-dedans n'appartenait à
aucun réseau on faisait notre petit truc
avec le personnel tout le monde faisant
ce faisant ça bénévolement
d'une part pour rendre service à nos
concitoyens et d'autre part un peu pour
narguer les allemands si vous voulez y m
il y avait il y avait un certain plaisir
à narguer les allemands au moment de la
démarcation francis fontaine était un
enfant il a précieusement conservé les
notes de son père et se souvient de la
vie quotidienne est très compliqué pour
toute la famille
pratiquement tous les vierzonnais avait
deux métiers ma mère était femme de
ménage au bourgneuf et la personne chez
qui elles allaient être soi disant
travailler était femme de ménage en
ville
ce qui permettait d'avoir des hausses
baisses pour aller travailler lui dire
qu'elle mentait elle mentait voilà alors
je j'ai su qu'elle passait du courrier
parce qu'elle a mené son tricot pelote
de laine à l'époque et il court y omeyer
faisait toute sa brosse pelote de laine
el had et faisait de l'autre côté puis
et revenait comme ça son père faisait
partie d'un réseau parisien
bélie thermopyles son travail
d'ingénieur lui permettait de se
déplacer d'environ sans éveiller les
soupçons
lavez la gestion des deux parties de la
ville alors il le cantonnier données
avec le gars qui voulait passer chacun
un balai et nettoyer les caniveaux
il passait en nettoyant les caniveaux
river de l'autre côté le gars partent et
puis le cantonnier revenait tout seul
faire passer le prochain
[Musique]
ingénieur commerçants agents
administratifs médecins ou prêtres mais
aussi paysans les passeurs s'organise
seuls ou en réseau
ils connaissent bien terrain les
endroits moins surveillée où l'on peut
passer à gué sur le cher il résiste
ainsi à l'occupant en contournant les
règles à leur manière maurice renaudat
était ouvrier agricole dans une ferme
il avait 16 ans trop jeune pour partir
au st lô le service du travail
obligatoire pour les allemands la maison
familiale se situe en zone libre
ma mère elle habitait alors près du
bureau ta mort à saint georges sera
précieux alors le bureau de tabac
c'était bon c'était une épicerie
c'est un bistrot je sais le il faisait
un peu tout là dedans il faisait un peu
tout et puis ça h arrivée que la nuit
est bien dit penseurs qui avait fait
passer des gens le cheikh abu leil les
groupes de clandestins jusqu'à ce bureau
de tabac où on les faisait pencher
et puis une grange il de la paille pour
le reste de la nuit dans dans la grange
est reparti dans le matin de 40 à 43
la population tente de passer en fraude
des marchandises ou des personnes par
tous les moyens y compris les cortèges
funéraires
c'est la fameuse histoire du corbillard
de virson en zone libre vous n'aviez pas
d'église donc quelqu'un qui était
enterrée quelqu'un qui mouraient à
vierzon bourgneuf et est enterré à
vierzon bourgneuf mais le passage obligé
pour la cérémonie funéraire c'était
l'église de vierzon ville donc il y
avait le corps passer dans un sens la
ligne de démarcation et après la
cérémonie de repasser dans l'autre sens
donc dans le sens
zone libre zone occupée y avait quelques
personnes qui suivaient le corps la
famille puis zone occupée zone libre il
y avait un petit peu plus de personnes
ont là les allemands ont pas été dupes
très longtemps parce qu'il voyait bien
le manège l'abbé farce et a été quand
même condamné à six mois de prison
les arrestations sur dénonciations sont
nombreuses 1500 allemands sont présents
à vierzon et très vite et se rendre
compte des fuites qui existe sur cette
frontière d'une centaine de kilomètres
dans le cher c'est pourquoi l'armée
allemande fait ces photos de propagande
elle met en scène de fausse arrestation
pour montrer qu'à surveille chaque mètre
carré le long du cher dans les campagnes
le docteur cliquer faisait passer des
réfugiés à guillet derrière son jardin
sa femme s'occupait des faux papiers
les contrôles des allemands ont mis un
terme à leurs activités de passeurs
c'est tout simplement la reste à une
arrestation à vierzon de candidats au
passage que lui n'avait pas encore
rencontré mais qu'ils avaient sur eux le
nom et l'adresse du docteur cliquez donc
du coup ils sont venus le chercher
ils l'ont pris ils l'ont emmené
questionné direction bourges le bordiot
ensuite drancy ensuite buchwald et puis
donc il est revenu en 1945 et c'est à ce
moment là qu'il a fait vraiment ses
études de médecine il est resté à paris
est décédé à paris en 1956 mais des
suites de mauvais traitements qu'il
avait eue en camp de concentration
passeur une activité très risqué selon
le voisin a également été arrêté en mai
un policier de la gestapo s'était fait
passer pour un clandestin qui voulaient
franchir la ligne
finalement nous avons été jugés à paris
on a quand même mieux 2 février valait
chef de réseau ils ont été fusillés au
mont valérien
on a eu quatre déporté en allemagne et
le reste ça a été des peines beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus mince par exemple moi
je croyais que j'avais trois mois puis
finalement il vient de retrouver aux
archives que j'en avais eu quatre mais
pour elle faire passer la ligne à
plusieurs dizaines de personnes
gratuitement ce n'est pas forcément de
la résistance on peut pas se vanter
d'avoir été résistant on l'a pas fait
pour obéir à londres on l'a fait d'eux
de nous mêmes les promesses de churchill
disant qu'on gagnerait la guerre moi je
n'y croyais pas sincèrement je n'y
croyais pas alors le passeur était-il un
résistant qui s'ignorent un héros
anonymes ou bien un qui se
faisait payer et profiter ainsi des
misères de la guerre la question agite
iman du passeur pause
la question même de la notion
d'engagement de la résistance en 40 41
certains en font passer la ligne de
démarcation surtout pour rendre service
pour pour certains d'entre eux et puis
donc il n'y a pas forcément une
conscience d'engagement résistant et
puis peu à peu aussi il ya une
organisation qui se met en place et donc
c'est passeur son compte est contactée
par d'autres résistants et donc ils ont
conscience qu'ils agissent donc dans une
organisation au sein au sein d'une
filière et puis parfois effectivement il
ya aussi des personnes qui font passer
la ligne de démarcation sans volonté de
résister pour autant c'est à dire que
certains effectivement vont se refaire
rémunéré gentil en fait
avantage de cette situation mais ils
prennent aussi ce des vrais des vrais
risques
donc on va dire que ce sont des passeurs
qui font de la résistance mais qui sont
pas vraiment résistants les histoires de
passeurs ont aussi marqué la mémoire de
thénioux petit village berrichon de 600
âmes presque posés sur la ligne de
démarcation la voie de chemin de fer
longeant le canal de berry et le cher
qui servait de frontière naturelle
un panneau en français et en allemand
interdisait de traversée de se baigner
ou même de cas noté en barque
c'est annie thibault qui l'a retrouvé
par hasard passionné d'histoire
elle a recueilli les témoignages des
habitants et de nombreux documents de
cette époque les barques était interdite
alors été confisqué et il ya eu un
arrêté de la préfecture où les gens
devaient donner leur bac dans ce qu'on
fait les passeurs c'est qu'ils ont coulé
leur barque mais pas coulés en la
personne bien sûr et l'ont rempli d'eau
et à chaque passage il fallait écopé
sortir la marque de l'eau traversé les
proches de pierre parent un cheminot qui
a été passeur à thénioux lui ont confié
son carnet
c'est un document très rare il reste peu
de preuves de ses passages illégaux les
patients à une démarcation tenait
souvent ce genre d'agenda mais les ont
cachés beaucoup ou détruits au moment où
il risquait d'être pris est donc
on en retrouve assez peu et donc dedans
vous avez plein adresse alors des
adresses de gens d'afrique du nord des
adresses de plein de gens en france mais
des adresses complètes et qui permettent
un peu de voir des passages c'était
énorme quand je veux dire c'était vous
avez des pages vous avez cinq personnes
de noter vous en avez vous en avez deux
ou trois mais et des gens de toute la
france une résistance rurales moins
connus mais pas moins honorable près du
canal c'est l'un des rares monuments sur
la ligne de démarcation où figurent les
noms des passeurs de taignons dont un
certain raymond toupet tué par les
allemands alors qu'il faisait traverser
un couple de clandestins embarque des
vies bouleversées par la guerre maurice
renaudat rejoint le maquis il est blessé
en août 44 militants communistes il est
devenu secrétaire de la cgt du cher
francis fontaine était architecte à
vierzon où il a surtout de rénover les
maisons anciennes sur l'ange voisins
elle a pris tardivement sa carte de
résistante et bientôt centenaire elle
poursuit toujours ses recherches et ses
réflexions sur la guerre car vous vivez
un truc comme ça par la force des choses
vous êtes obligés quand même qu'on le
veuille ou non
[Musique]
de s'installer dans cette vie anormale
et de vivre le plus normalement possible
dans une période de folie